okay Osama slow down please my I don't
have a butt God didn't give me a bottle
[Applause]
ironic right after Debbie said she had
no but she fell off the ass
did anyone check her neck is her neck
okay oh Debbie's First full dad usama's
family's home was rough to say the least
it started off on a bad note they put
upholstery on the toilet seat it's like
no no no no no no I can't have that Miss
Debbie experiencing a number of rude
Awakenings literally I'm good at making
do but this is making dope honey
including usama's family revealing that
they think she's taking him to the U.S
enough for himself
which Debbie shuts down real quick I am
moving here permanently
I bought all my things and suitcases to
live here forever
will Julian go get your mama to top it
all off Osama gives Debbie an ultimatum
and insults her at the same time
let's get into it
okay 90 day fan spam it's melissia
before we get into what I hope is Debbie
and usama's rock bottom so they can move
on let me give you a quick update on
Nicole and my mood I'm ready to leave
Egypt
Nicole is at her wit's end with life in
Egypt and she tells Mahmoud she's ready
to go back to the States asking him if
he's willing to join if his Visa gets
approved kind of like give any answer
now if I go to United States to use
Nicole I don't sure if people like
accept me as like I'm in Japan from
Middle East and I'm Muslim like maybe
it's be hard on me I don't know what to
do
this awful thing in a way it's within
gold
at least he's open to it but you know
that saying we take ourselves with us
wherever we go so yeah a change of
location might help temporarily but the
true problems between those two will
surface again no matter where they are
in the world today when I woke up I felt
at age 10 years and I look like I aged
10 years alright let's let's get into
Debbie's stressful first day living at
usama's parents house and let's keep in
mind Usama is planning for them to live
here for a month or two you know it's
very primitive here
the bathroom downstairs yes it has a
regular toilet but they put upholstery
on the toilet seat it's like no no no no
no no I can't have that just put toilet
paper on the seat or squat Debbie wait
no just put toilet paper on the seat we
already saw what happened with the
donkey I've been in third world
countries before and you know was able
to make do I'm good at making do but
this is making dope honey
the shower it's like a hole in the
ground with a whole garden hose it's
like we took an Act of God for me to get
ready I believe her I could imagine
Debbie in there struggling she goes on
to complain about their stairs there's
no railings on the stairs I don't know
why everyone's not walking around with a
neck braceman falling down the damn
stairs this ain't my Nest I'm telling
you that right now Debbie said
seven and I ain't used to
this I'm not about to get used to this
either get me the hell out of camera set
and you know it's one thing if you can't
afford a more enjoyable living space for
yourself but it's another one you can
but you're choosing to be uncomfortable
because you're sacrificing for your
boyfriend who you don't even kiss
couldn't be me I wanted to express my
appreciation for having me here once I
head downstairs Debbie gives usama's dad
some painting tools as a gift he was
extremely grateful for them but then he
brings up his excitement for usama's
bright future
in the states enough of himself
which catches Debbie by surprise
well I wanted to explain clearly so
everyone's on the same page everyone
knows I am moving here permanently
I bought all my things usama's sister is
looking like her dream just went down
the drain I guess it's just as
disappointing for Debbie to learn that
more than likely usama's been telling
his family that she plans to take him to
the U.S as it is for his family to learn
that that's not her plan who knows they
could have tied their future to his move
too so you you want to say here I mean
living to yourself
forever
I don't plan on living here I plan on
living in Rabat and coming here for you
know a weekend here and there I mean are
you okay
um
so Usama saying he has no problem
staying in Morocco
kind of confuses me did his family
really just assume that Debbie is taking
him to America or is he backtracking
things now trying to play it cool I
doubt that they just pulled that out of
nowhere
foreign
okay
I'm getting big time mixed signals I can
tell by their facial expressions that
they're shocked that I'm moving here
it's like what kind of song and dance
did Osama tell them he told them
something for osama's Dad to sit there
on the last episode and say age was
never a concern for him and your 24 year
old son is dating a 67 year old woman
come on now that's concerning to us and
we don't even know Usama things are
contradicting each other again and again
when I arrived in Morocco he said he
wanted me to go home after one or two
months and now they're saying oh I'm
taking their son to the United States
too
Osama
isn't going to the United States and
that wasn't our plan and now all of a
sudden everything's going ass backwards
no pun intended let's talk about
Debbie's fall off the donkey oh look at
his ears you want to play with me after
all the drama at home Usama and Debbie
go out to the farm to paint but Debbie
sees this donkey and becomes infatuated
with it
for me
30.
my party
I guess pretty is the donkey's name
either way Debbie starts singing to it
[Music]
wait let's pause here I was trying to
figure out if Debbie has Usama involved
in this serenade his hands are stretched
out like hers are but his face is
looking like side eye and Chloe
Irish
[Music]
Debbie is giving off Cinderella in her
60s Vibes our dreams
is a wish
Your Heart Makes
wardrobe and everything right I have
always had an affinity for animals and I
connect with them now I know some of you
might be judging Debbie for getting so
involved with this donkey and you might
think it's weird it is different but I
have respect for people who aren't
afraid to be themselves and literally do
what they want to do as long as they're
not being a creep or hurting anybody but
yeah what does Dr Seuss say we are all a
little weird and Life's a little weird
some people are just more comfortable
with expressing their weirdness you
but wait pause
look at this shot here she wants to talk
about those stairs this looks like an
accident waiting to happen that little
donkey I'm not riding any animal that's
smaller than me not too fat oh Shama
okay Osama slow down please but I don't
have a butt at first I was like what
does her butt have to do with her riding
a donkey is she talking about cushion
wise but y'all I Google everything so I
Googled it does your butt help you ride
a horse or a donkey better and for those
of you who were clueless to this like me
if there are any of you yes apparently
writing engages your glute muscles so
having strong glutes helps
look at The Learning Channel
learn something today
[Music]
okay Osama slow down please my I don't
have a butt God didn't give me a bottle
so my
[Applause]
mom
okay
I told you to be careful with the donkey
I always told you this because you will
fly yeah
no Miss Debbie you had no business
getting on that donkey in the first
place at least she's laughing and her
hips neck and back are intact Lord have
mercy why do I always do something
clumsy and Podunk it's like let me
retain my dignity and gather myself up
off the ground
but I love animals clearly Usama and
Debbie start to paint and Debbie brings
up looking for apartments in the capital
city and making plans for their future
so she can feel secure something Usama
tells her
he doesn't want to talk about right now
the right time to talk about the plants
now
it's time for creating you can do both
at the same time no I can't I have one
mind no two
attitude you can see Usama starts to get
really irritated by Debbie and all of a
sudden
he just hits below the Bell
you think I'm not patient yeah because
you want to do everything right here
right now I didn't want you to do it
right now I just wanted you to sketch an
outline of our future and we just
started I mean I would not do everything
in one day are you crazy
Debbie this is what you say
Who you calling crazy will not do
everything in one day
you are sick
you have the amount of seconds or
something
what
safe times what's going on with this
lady
I don't get it man so you think I'm
mentally ill
you're acting real cold-blooded right
now he is looking like a wolf in sheep's
clothing y'all remember when we first
met Debbie and she opened up about her
past experiences with love we thought so
as little girls you know we thought oh I
Prince Charming's coming well they don't
teach you that you know sometimes it's
the big bad wolf
see
the thing about being free-spirited and
open-hearted it's great but it can be a
double-edged sword if you just allow
everybody in because you think they have
a heart like you do it's important to
practice discernment because there are
wolves out there who will sniff out your
kindness and take advantage of it I want
to talk about serious things and you act
like oh you're crazy you're mentally ill
so we talk about the plans
our plants is you will come here and
bring me to the USA and I will go to
work there and we start our left there
we can guarantee the future here this is
our plan and I went from this time never
change it if you don't accept us we
can't stop all this
well looks like it's time to pack those
bags Miss Debbie I'll be darned if I
ever live with a man who talks to me
like that it's slick scary in my opinion
she's now entered into the danger zone
it's time to go and next week it looks
like things escalate even more between
them
you should be ashamed of yourself the
way you treated me I'm creepy I'm bad
I'm ugly I'm I'm son of okay
we were planning to go to the USA yes or
no no no it's not about a Visa the other
life you're a cold-blooded snake
based off that clip it sounds like Usama
is saying at some point Debbie told him
they're going to the U.S
whatever we'll see as the saga continues
one thing I do know though I can't wait
for this tell-all I need a real-time
update
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time
[Music]